um this is not going to be a super long
stream I guess I'm not sure I didn't
plan it so much before my main thing is
I want to test this adjusted screen
setup I hope this is better the board
will be a little bit a little bit bigger
and I think it's easier to follow the
games and also adjusted the
notifications a little bit so I hope
this is an improvement what I should
have done actually there was kind of
stupid not to do that let me let me do
this quickly didn't didn't open up a
twitch twitch window which is kind of
stupid a chat window I mean let me do
that before I am completely screwing
this up so I've got a shed window active
yayyy
so and so on let's join the how we put
it arena I'm going to play some some
bullet games oh okay
so we get an e 45 after all not a 3/5 is
really bad
okay
it's not easy for white f2 is the
problem this is also good to take could
have taken the Queen and that would have
been better but rook takes f2 will be
that that will be tough we have 10
seconds mate and now I am playing this
this is bullet good a tournament not
taking challenges at the moment I'm
going to do that tomorrow I guess my
healthy cat oops
give me g4 okay and the main purpose was
to test the different different setup
here so please give me some some
feedback if you've got the possibility
is that looking better than before and
the board is bigger almost as as big as
possible let's say and
[Music]
so I should win this I think I could
hide the menu on the top that's true but
would that help it's it's just a little
bit bigger yeah but it's possible that's
true
anything you can fold it to some yep a
trap like this so we've got made yeah
that's true I could hide this thing on
the on the top right we're getting there
yeah I don't need the coordinates but
some of the viewers might so I am move
down of the slay or normal stuff
threatening mate never know they might
wanna get
hmm Bishop takes f6 I can actually was
actually not so terrible but I can take
here first maybe yeah you see I changed
this following the stuff with following
here I think this is a bit better not
irritating so much so I wanted to check
here and have to not forget that this is
bullet no I would be one of course
twitch shows that I'm offline really I
mean I don't have the twitch site open
now I only have the cheddar open that's
a bit weird
that was a very silly loss by the way I
look more at the chat and and everything
the net the actual game okay Louis
Garcia I have a very knowing pin here
and have three notes not going to play a
three so let's go ahead and try to
arrest the King okay let's open things
up he's defending here somehow take this
and get on to this critical diagonal
towards the king stop defending so well
this should be six if he takes it can
almost pre-move and over over yeah I
need to catch up here I'm late anyway
and then lost this this game yellow to
no joke chess good to good seeing you in
the chat we need to talk about which you
need to show me a few things okay
oops okay thanks
Princess Peach who is that the limping
Knight try to work with pre moves that
works sometimes play play for simple
threats 90s g6 is a pretty huge threat
huh do it let's not be too fancy I
doesn't react to that at all wasn't
exactly subtle
so taking now hmm if I could back it's
probably better I'm keeping more stuff
on the board I'm threatening Bishop
takes f6 now immediately mating
okay here maybe him so the night cannot
move yeah but just at 9:00 she's six
mmm okay so it wasn't super convincing
this is not so convincing probably still
a lot better with the game continues
[Music]
doesn't it was on time it no it does
okay so where I'm getting closer getting
closer
just 11 minutes left oh my god it's
going to be difficult
okay I need some quick quick play em for
a headstrong
96 check is probably strong and it
doesn't work not at least not
objectively mate on g1 will be low
bidder will be the finisher here somehow
threatening made on g1
oh that's funny
hey Green Jones is leading this okay he
wanted some bullet after after losing
that crazy game today to Magnus that's
cool
yeah thanks father for the follow I
think this is better now it's less and
less annoying I mean less annoying
sounds wrong I hope it's not annoying at
all but it was definitely quite quite a
pain before there's this big window
I didn't see that so I have a pawn up
here and I've got the bishop against
Knight look sorry good to keep this for
the moment no go here now that blunder
this frigging pawn it's great it was
already completely winning for me then I
blunder it free night okay
I'm closing in but I'm not catching
first place I mean Jones is not going to
concede so many points and yeah that
early loss was pretty bad it's got a
funny fighter and it's actually not so
clear but what can you do
[Music]
like this doing the guide is super hero
of this game and it has taken everything
that's crazy oh my goodness maybe I get
third place that's certainly possible in
the game against Dwayne would be nice of
course the good old elephant gambit
the castles this is coming oh thanks for
the donation slicky McNuggets that's
great thank you
um tea drinking tea so good to control
Queen h4 or this one you can take on f3
which are overlooked
lastly yes
for losing against African elephant
gambit okay that was really silly okay
so yeah the my new e4 abattoir is going
to be on chess of all that's true I'm a
race okay c'mon let's try to bring you
better with the berserk okay I could
have taken deform but doesn't matter I
hope well played but like a by white I'm
sorry
yeah well played that black would be
cool just and it's it's dangerous it's
it's dangerous play the bishop on a7 is
just very strong
Knight is hanging now that's all green
age 1 checkmate Princess Peach
whatever that is but dick I don't know
anymore how does it work
this is probably wrong yeah there's
something wrong about that I made this
the same friggin mistake and then
in-game not so long ago and stumbled
into this crap okay the worst is over
so good somewhat better ending here
we can stop the age I'm so slow no help
[Applause]
okay so it didn't turn out too well lost
a bunch of raining but again I mostly
wanted to test the test screen and so on
that that felt felt okay
so um what to do that um there is
another bullet arena when is that
happening
two minutes oh come on let's do let's do
that let's go for a second bullet arena
this time I'm starting right at the very
beginning no catching up to do simply
play play some games I'm not sure if you
have Dwayne Jones again again on again
so in two minutes time so any suggestion
to improve the screen design let's say
yeah I could get rid of the oh I don't
know the translation of Shriner wouldn't
hmm
Hawaii wins the so funny were funny
would
I wonder what the right English word
would be yeah big dog it's the histor
one by one translation but that doesn't
mean it it basically usually first to
people who are a person who would be
just very mm yeah maybe somewhat mean
yes son of a [ __ ]
Yeah right some of the which would be
kind of okay yeah what kind would would
be it would fit I'm not sure I know what
the German means like being yeah but it
says more it's meant and more of a
positive way more as it's so 30 seconds
to go and I'm not actually the favorite
down I'm not the favorite we chick is
leading this tournament by raiding the
tournament yeah it seemed it's not
actually a compliment and stuff the same
zero okay so here we go again we take
our first game
[Music]
so plate 95 before didn't do it so um
[Music]
this is good for white but still yeah
okay it's not not so clear not so clear
actually no okay because of FO hanging
it wasn't so clear Wow I did not play
this well I really really hate how I
played that
[Music]
Wow and that whole game was completely
completely screwed up I don't know what
I did here I have played 94 Wow
legging so bad I don't know nothing
likes on my end this time I think my
connection seems really fine okay I have
to get back into this tournament that
that that game was really terrible
really
I cannot even bizarre bad oh I'm not I
don't know after after - this
differently I have to sit correctly and
so on and then then go into bullet mode
not yet into the right mindset for
bullet games a camera is a bit on the
board yeah that's true
yeah let's do it like that so can I have
somehow get back into this tournament we
are very weird game yeah which is why
doing here
very strange everything don't expect a
single move that he plays yeah I don't
know he can probably just drop the
bishop back no tags and blundering
pieces the whole time what am I doing
here
hello what I don't get it I don't get it
I'm blundering pieces the whole time I
know it's bullet but I still don't learn
the pieces usually no not like every
other move Oh God it's not going to end
well and it's a pretty terrible position
[Music]
okay he stumbled into checkmate
hey the tea player I'm the time player I
forgot to exchange against the French
and now I have to play this oh my god
yeah I mean this is good for white but
it's not really an easy position to play
in bullet chest and bullet I would
always prefer black in this position 94
is very awkward now okay
[Music]
let's get the King out of this the
situation okay not not to stumble into
this well ah difficult to claim it's so
difficult to play with no time finally
and get some sort of coordination in
this position the king is running all
over the place looking at f8 this way
okay
[Music]
I'm really slow ah but what am I doing
here I shouldn't probably play bullet
after working ten hours before I don't
know ah come on I still should get
something going here it was pretty
terrible come on there should be three
of course Kim nobody expects that Bishop
c5 gets played okay yeah still warming
up that's well yeah warming up is good
but the tournament is probably over the
moment I have warmed up that looks good
got everything I'm not control I mean
I'm on 22nd place and I'm probably the
best player in the tournament I know
somebody is higher rated but I don't
think anyway but it's so much a question
of good shape okay that's an excellent
end game for white I can still blunder
stuff that's are so stupid so stupid
when I'm doing it me five of course I
was just thinking okay winner tempore
they have added this of course entirely
irrelevant
now he's got this excellent night only
five I'm winning on time here but that
stuff I was pretty bad okay come on
let's fight him I'm not going to win
this anymore I'm just playing too many
too many bad games but still okay then
let's not remove this yeah white is
under huge pressure him threatening to
run back the piece with a fork so I
would end up being a piece up actually
see four hands I tried to be as quick as
possible so then I'm a better chance to
catch up okay 13th place our wheat chick
is also not doing great the first the
first seat no seems to be a tough
tournament silly five stuff yeah it's
true I think Lee chess has many good
speed players quick players because
people who like to play those very quick
time controls bullet up controls they
are drawn to each s because of the
excellent server performance it just
makes a lot of sense to player because
it's just so quick okay so position is
winning but am i winning it's the thing
hmm I was thinking this is covered
actually I'm helps making the stupidest
mistakes is really weird almost like a
loose in Asia
[Music]
Wow no Yahoo Ches
I think I actually played on Yahoo chess
once but it's it's been a really long
time ago so I get four points now four
wins
so my still got some some chances never
lose hope
yeah hello - Fineman and fine thanks
actually been working all day almost but
some good enjoy the lessons and now
doing this quick stream
okay I need some more firepower here see
I can double he on the second no he
allows me this doubling it's quite
surprising
isn't that totally winning for me weird
okay 16 yeah I'm not doing any
tournament coverage at the moment this
is just too much overtime the time eater
if you convert our Stila it's like two
to three hours per day and I don't have
that it's very if he likes play so on
full scale attack mate made body won't
be seven
ah come on Ned let's not run the clock
down now please
I want to catch up here thank you three
points three points behind hmm ah good
we check again yeah I lost pretty
terrible it to him the first game so I
have to play better now
95 it's a good move now that didn't go
too well I'm talking we have to we have
to still try ok no mate mate frigging
mate
I'm not threatening anything him which
eSports what a pain I losing two times
against the sky when you're right in the
middle of catching up you know play in
the middle of Atonement why did I choose
this frigging opening of all openings
sometimes it doesn't make any sense
I mean if you win then this is kind of
it doesn't look like I'm doing that it
will take ages that was a stupid choice
a really stupid opening choice
i deep it was here yes yeah long time no
see
good to see you on Twitch game take this
I'm really playing very stupid stuff
here this tournament don't really know
why it's been a somewhat long day but so
there's no excuse for playing so badly
okay so let's see can I win this ending
I hope I can as c4 it's the absolutely
worst move in the position ah no it's
pretty awful yeah well okay maybe third
place always have to find go wants to to
strive to that yellow font
trying to trap his Queen and Bishop
everyone
my queen can actually escape or the way
but it's still quite okay to have the
bishop on d3 it is probably pretty good
position for me but how to get this
attack going I have to maybe I just take
actually and it's not convincing oh my
god
I got it God means it doesn't matter
it's tough to generate something my twin
on time we into a tick wins this thing I
don't believe it
yeah okay in fact won against him then I
could be in that position but I played
those two pretty terrible games against
them okay okay it was this stuff again
and this is this isn't even that great
this more I stumbled into this
it's much easier for white to play this
pollution is the problem
okay I'm better but instead something
that I can convert I mean it's not
winning of course
[Music]
I'm down a million minutes here I don't
know what's going on here am i playing
so slowly I think I do
unbelievable
I don't know very strange I know it
that guy tricks me I don't know I'm just
too slow so just one one game left in
this tournament doesn't really it was
really bad
now I'm just playing those two
tournaments and probably also the call
it quits after that its own it's already
again fairly late yet closing into
midnight time that's the good position
actually I tried to reach the chat yeah
I do
[Music]
it's maybe not a good idea to do in
bullet but I mean if I don't read the
[ __ ] what's the point I've seen other
streams here where they play a bullet
and never say a thing I mean what's the
point
am I somehow meeting I would like to
cheer meet you I don't see how though
mate no did that count I don't know I
will give a discount okay so that was
two bullet tournaments and they would
but were pretty awfully played by me so
don't copy that didn't really didn't
really yeah set a good example how to
play one more one more tournament you
mean what do we have no there's only the
hyper bullet arena and I know I know I'm
going to suck royally at that no no no
you know what
I have no challenges and I can't do I
would play like half an hour of
challenges that I would do that but if
you like that I could do that but longer
not longer I need you and need to get
get some sleep so give me give me them
challenges no matter what time so okay
let's go Fedor time control whatever
let's play the better off and boil the
white player to death it is some
sometimes a bit boring but I've played
quite a bit the end hey not 45 plus 45
something in the Blitz
bullet range would be good yeah let's go
three and lower something like that so
I've completed my development
hmm well white is not really threatening
to take on g6m but okay now 5-0 is also
fine absolutely I take a 5-0 challenge
okay it's proven 94 but I only play like
I said for half an hour so I'm I cannot
blame cannot play like 20 games or so I
came hmm yeah I wonder if g5 is actually
something I should do it's tough to
unpin g6
yeah maybe g6 Bishop g7
it's still a bit bit of an awkward pin
well white is definitely better yeah
arrows yes let's do arrows um yeah so
that that much for the arrows
I can now unpin with Queen a5 which is
not really helpful
I guess not a move you love to play that
didn't work out too well
I could actually no he come at that and
I thought c3 and then snatched a true
what would be extremely cheeky pawn grab
I'm a taking deform taking that food I
don't know okay yeah I probably want the
Queen back into the game but let's try
to do it while being somewhat annoying
at least attack b2 and b3 okay b3 Queen
c3 Bishop h7 is a good way to lose the
game yeah like here here I cannot take
now here but I just wanted to get the
Queen back into the game
hmm what about f6 yeah f6 Bishop f4
what's the deal
ob should be 8 maybe hmm that's true
that is true
so maybe activate the night the night
wasn't good anyway angling for Knight f5
I got 15 challenges so I have to
disappoint quite a number of of you yeah
but they have to catch some sleep
from from this exact minute in 8 hours
let's say there's a there's someone
coming to my place to try to fix my
internet issue so I really have to be
ready and that's time so I'm trying to
play Knight e4 which she prevented so
how to oh I actually forgot that this is
possible okay just try to get oh the
time didn't pay much attention to the
time
come on what are you doing to me
I'm just letting this this this promote
oh my god what am i doing am playing
like a complete [ __ ] yeah I knew when I
started this stream it's going to be a
bit tricky because I was I wasn't
feeling very fresh but I'm really played
terribly Wow yeah it was a good place to
or white I mean it was equal the whole
time but it yeah I screw it up
so we're going to play of this of this
list yeah that's difficult what I want
to wrestle Barry let's do a bullet game
I mean easy prey and bullet it seems
today obviously doing it looks very
strange
no challenges I find that I play some
some challenges to school someone
suggests the screw blitz arena but this
is like one our way and I really came
out to stay on for one hour
I like those tournaments really do
myself I have to as I said catch some
sleep and try to play some guys ahead
and plate last time so navel-gazing fo I
don't know
I'm working on an e4 repertoire for
white not for black so you cannot really
say there's a focus or something I'm
just with white yeah I'm taking on every
single possible answer and the focus
will be line set not so much relying on
memorization but rather yeah rather
simple to learn lines of possible so I'm
wing and lots of material like Christmas
gifts for me me
okay so phonology phonology 93 is
somewhat I am let's not go there it's
somewhat decent pre-move I wanted to
save it it's pretty terrible against a
Scandinavian and you get that off for
the often let's cancel
maybe now black should actually take the
pawn and deform didn't that somewhat
passive setup so I'm going to try to be
as aggressive as possible punish that f7
is hanging so I'm taking this it takes
you through this check but I managed to
smash through on f7 on so it looks kind
of like it shouldn't work for him I
could have taken on a fade already no I
see it it made okay and it was a bit too
much this attack
also one minute oh I have a 26-0 score
against Hawaii Wow
that opening is called the fret if I'm
not mistaken
f5 everything has the name I didn't
refute it
hey this is actually quite okay for
black it's really okay
Queen g-form
this is actually somewhat dangerous
really is wasn't able to cover G to
Queen Queen g7 coming oh my god
will I lose against this that that would
be terrible
well it's possible
okay if I take F force yeah I don't see
anything
[Music]
I have absolutely no time Wow okay it
was very scary anybody haven't played
enough done yeah yeah I don't know it's
tough the same doing it basically you
know in a random way John that's our
come on let's go
so with the exchange on three it's three
minutes yeah I have to keep that in mind
yeah I'm getting the pawn back here this
is not a super dangerous approach no I'm
not going to play f3 and Kiev - I don't
like to play this crap I like to play
somewhat decent opening that list
she's lethal what is that
yeah could play we're white very solid
hmm no you might just take play Knightly
form Bishop d3 is also interesting I
place this 195 is actually a good move
white is just trading everything Jim not
nothing great Jim c5 no maybe this
how does one get good at speeches it's a
good question probably don't copy but
I'm what I'm doing you know but I think
the main thing is just to just a plain I
mean especially I mean online blitzen
over the board blitz there are there are
different things in some way but you
have a one part of it is just being
quick if you have them if you are online
it's the mouse and over the board it is
simply placing the pieces quickly yeah I
know to all of our chests yeah I think
she's also streaming right I haven't
watched the stream but I I caught them I
caught the name on on the leeches front
page what am I doing here
what hey I'm really doing everything to
lose this yeah look rookie fights almost
working almost working yeah in over the
board you don't have pre moves that is
definitely a difference but it's still
of practice they are playing playing
quick moves okay what am i doing you
have to take you Wow okay I can check
here and take on f2 g7 hangs we're just
going to be terrible okay I'm doing this
first yeah f2 is hanging that's the only
oh I can take that now I can take
threatening made yeah those books are
not helping with the king
threatening mayhem made into
so am I going for this chick when did
you forget three so I'm not laying this
chick and what now some creature f5
could happen um playable
I'm just not it's this is a bit slow
might so be good I don't know
Queen f5 I'm worried about Queen f5 the
whole time
and it's a snap
so easy to do with no time we tough Wow
okay so thanks for the game janessa I
was really tough I was probably lost
there I would have would be weird if not
okay so mmm it's just such a normal
Astaire I don't know enough Tanya
something quicker maybe I'm more in the
Greek more atomic chess oh my god no
let's not go atomic I really have no
clue how that works even come on let's
be annoying you probably not great using
the pin let's play an endgame come on oh
no endgame but that happens yeah typical
no I have not read all of the books most
of it is instructional material by you
like pull me that you used to
yeah get exercise for students and so on
so it's not stuff you you read like from
cover to cover
okay so where it's the mate 93 mate and
May next okay so oh well I won Braga
13 let's see there it looks like a
library yeah
the funny thing is that a little bit
more than two years ago I sold four to
five hundred books actually to get more
space I had so much stuff so here we
have a nimzo-indian very young a
well-known structure the sexes play to
develop the bishop and i think that i
have a fairly comfortable version here
he has some issues with the c3 pawn not
sure how he's going to keep it okay this
way again if I go Bishop d5 now probably
he has to trade otherwise I would win
see dream
I read books everyday I mean again most
of it is like they are manual self to be
used for for for for for chess training
but I use books daily and absolutely
these are sitting there for my lesson
today okay so I'm winning see three
that's nice to get it's important that C
three is covering or can be used with c4
to cover d5 okay offer the queen Trey
and he cannot take on a eight because
Luke a eight will trap the cloud so I
have the C file in control and d5 very
nice
okay so let's play the same game I have
six I'm going to control the e5 square
so that also my King it gets some good
route into the game and now the slide is
traveling to c4 unless it's getting
stopped which which happened so okay
ninety-four it's a bit annoying you
facing night before okay what what did
what do I think of the London system hmm
yeah it's it's a good practical weapon
of course because it's so easy to play
especially in quickie games but it's not
an opening that I would recommend to
play in every single game because it is
sometimes a little bit a little bit
one-sided let's say it gets repetitive
and yeah in some in some way it makes
the game's a little bit less interesting
as a learning experience because the
patterns are somewhat similar so I
usually don't recommend to play this
every single game but rather plain warm
yeah more mainline ish openings but
there's of course nothing wrong with the
opening some good resources to learn the
Italian game from oh I'm not totally
sure the last things the latest things
as far as correct that is all gone just
to any form and they were quite good but
on a somewhat higher level also so it
depends a bit what you're looking for so
I'm covering this and I completely did
not see that there's
okay not playing as well it was a fairly
it was I had a good position but there
are no mods currently I'm the only one I
think okay um let's see I don't want you
don't want to screw this up italia but
it's going to be difficult to win
definitely okay well now I'm getting de
for it Wendy's trading into the key
opponent that should help
it's promote we have ten seconds
yeah and one brother resigns so I'm
going to go for one more game and then
I'm going to call it quits and go to bed
so maybe two minutes here two minute
game sounds fine against Jessie let's
see I'm going to come see 45 US line
continues to give me excellent results
okay 97 I'm really doing stupid moves
I really have looked at this and
established that the night should go to
e 7 and I simply forgot to do it ok I
mean this is not like terrible also but
the night is better on e7 it really is
ok this is this is getting interesting
ok I'm going for the direct attack look
if it takes it I go 96 must be dangerous
the bishop on a7 is the key here putting
loads of pressure on the whites position
now H forward drop
extremely it's an extremely tough line
to play for white in those shorter time
controls it even will be difficult in
longer time controls but in blitz bullet
it's terrible for white for terrible for
what to play okay guys thank you for
tuning in on the stream it was very
enjoyable so even though I didn't play
all that well especially in the food
tournaments that that sucked
um yeah please take note that I'm going
to be online again tomorrow at 11 p.m.
Central European Time similar time to
today and I'm not going I'm not sure
what I'm going to do there but
yeah make sure to tune in thanks for
watching bye bye